by now most film fans know that when the
credits roll on a Marvel Studios movie
the real fun is about to begin
that's because Marvel loves to set up
future franchise instalments with
teasers Easter eggs and inside jokes
hidden in scenes during the credits
usually this means one or two small bits
during or after the credits but with
guardians of the galaxy volume two
writer director James Gunn has taken
things to a whole new level with five
yes five credits scenes some are
important and some are just goofy but
either way we've got you covered with
explanations for every credit scene in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 oh and
just so everyone's on the same page
spoilers ahead the arrow in the first
bonus scene yondu's right-hand man crag
Lin wears his former captain's robotic
fin to try and harness the power of his
whistle controlled arrow of course it
goes horribly wrong it looks like a
funny scene but actually this is a very
complicated Easter Egg referencing the
ascension of Kang the Conqueror in
Avengers forever number 9 and no just
kidding this scene is exactly what it
seemed like a funny one-off joke hey not
every scene has to be filled with secret
meaning okay
the original guardians unlike the first
credit scene the second is actually
jam-packed with Marvel Comics law those
Ravagers who show up for your news
funeral some of them are actually
members of the original guardians of the
galaxy team from the 1970s comic books
stacker Martin X Charlie 27 and Aleta
are all original flavor guardians while
mainframe and Krueger are also important
characters in the old-school guardians
of the galaxy comic book universe and
considering the big-name actors Marvel
signed up for the roles like Sylvester
Stallone Michelle Yeoh and Ving Rhames
chances are pretty good we're going to
see a lot more of these guys in future
movies even if Stallone doesn't have the
best track record with comic book movies
ah Adam warlock if you were wondering
why the people in your theater erupted
it with screens of pure joy during the
third credit scene
the answer is Adam warlock the mystery
being inside the metal cocoon built by
the vengeful High Priestess Aisha
Marvel fans have been eagerly awaiting
warlocks arrival in the movie universe
because a gold skinned cosmic Savior
have been a key player in basically
every important fan a storyline in
comics history Adam warlock a Santos's
archenemy an avatar of life dedicated to
stopping Thanos and his obsession with
death with Thanos said to finally take
center stage in 2018 s Avengers infinity
war fans have been wondering how Marvel
would manage to tell the story without
Adam warlock now we can all finally rest
easy if we can stop freaking out I am
Groot the fourth credit scene is pretty
much just a self-explanatory joke about
baby grew to grubbing up to become team
Groot
we're not sure if this means teen Groot
will be in the sequel or if this is a
bridge to explain why is all grown up as
adult Groot in the team's next
appearance
[Applause]
but considering this brief clip is
funnier than just about any half-hour
family sitcom on primetime television
right now we can't be the only ones
hoping ABC develops her growing up a
Groot spinoff right stand the man for
nearly 20 years now Stan Lee has been
making cameos in Marvel movies as a
result a fan Theory developed along the
way that Stan isn't actually playing
different characters but instead is a
disguised member of the alien race known
as the watchers who observe and record
stories of mankind without interfering
in events now Lee and director James
Gunn have confirmed it with a fantastic
bit where Stan is telling a group of
watches about all the stories he's
participated in which of course are the
other Marvel movies it further proves
what we've known all along Stan truly is
the man you know I guess one person can
make a difference
enough said thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]